[Musica]
peccato che è un gioco di merda
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo video
sono pa vigente ci siamo trovati su
happy days
ciao zio ciao ciao ciao ciao ciao ciao
zia come stai
al 6 bella tu si che sennò non sei bello
dispiace ragazzi che sia un gioco così
di merda però scoperto che l'ha fatto
raffa e il quinto e juliette raffaele
juliet che i problemi avete comunque
ragazzi erano rimasti purtroppo al
secondo livello me ne mancano due che
cazzo già posso fare allora rimasto
partiamo perché con tutta la calma del
mondo non mi ricordo
ok così si cuoce la trappola sirene
adesso che ci sia da ragazzino finirlo e
perché non ne faccio un altro non
signore sull'ansia no madonna cosa sto
facendo
non mi ricordo quanto mancava alla fine
del livello perché anche perché non l'ho
mai visto alla fine del livello
purtroppo morire si è morto e poi sono
esploso è morto e poi sono esploso
almeno questo ok su un perfetto no si ok
adesso non lo so ero arrivato qua diome
ok questo mi ricordo che cade questo qua
quindi vado più avanti c'ero quasi cazzo
il bello è che il bello è che non c'è un
bello in questo gioco è un gioco gioco
significa divertirsi gioco io gioco
perché mi diverto che cazzo gioco a
stoner sono caduto prima ok perfetto
stavo cadendo nella trappola non sono
caduto to crepi anche tua madre bravo
bravo devo andare di su così no così no
così forse no food o minchia e che ci
voleva tanto il problema adesso rimane a
1 quale tra i due
siccome non so quale tra le due me la fa
prende intercooler chiamò alla mamma che
la mamma so sempre cosa fare
ciao mamma
bene bene scorta mi sono un consiglio
veloce sinistro destra sinistra grazie
mamma la mamma ha detto sinistra
ragazzine sinistra sia
[Musica]
la mamma sempre a fottutamente ragione
quindi andiamo sul tronco bene brava che
ho fatto anche il vino perfetto
cosa faccio adesso sono a mezz'aria non
so cosa sto facendo io vado avanti
ok ok no non hockey un cazzo no
dall'inizio come dall'inizio ci ho messo
40 minuti arriva la perché mi fate
ripartire ogni volta da zero cazzo
adesso no no no no no ok perfetto
stavo sbagliando come prima che vado
dove c'è l'erba no perché dove c'è
l'erba crepo non so su quale andare
agazzi questa sinistra si ok
bene io so già che tanto se salgono
normalmente crepo quindi qualcosa devo
fare lega giu ma guardate un traguardo
ma guarda te un famigliare incazzato
qualcuno ha voglia di spiegarmi cosa
dovrà dare tanto credo di dover andare
quello a destra ma cazzo fai
no no no ma che cazzo fai matech perché
perché prima funzionava e adesso non
funziona più o ci siamo siccome non va
nella prima nella seconda ma [ __ ]
va direttamente sull'erbetta ma perché
ma perché salto e adesso funzione prima
no e allora qualche problema ai al
cervello spiega me lo permetta l'ho
presa e l'ho presa
[Musica]
bene proprio porca [ __ ] della
[ __ ] opportuna fai una pausa
vorresti fare una pausa
io ti vorrei amma tutti borries quarta
rig 46 pezzi e venderlo un in che al
mercato delle pulci di alberobello
ragazzi e l'ultimo livello della demo
che ovviamente non ce la farò mai a fare
perché mi rifiuto vero però che mi
rifiuto vero che mi rifiuto dove il
cestino che mi rifiuto quindi fatemi
capire quale dovrebbe essere mio
obiettivo in questa merda che bello e
vado passionali sopra ovviamente no ok
che però a gene è bello bello breve ma è
piaciuto però mi è molto piaciuto però
per essere un inizio non è male ragazzi
ho fatto di peggio basta ragazzino
deciso tutto in una botta sola tutto in
una botta sola ci siamo non lo sento da
adesso ci siamo ragazzi tutto in una
botta sola voglio vincere voglio tutto
in una botta soccer è perfetta per avere
botta di culo assurda rispondere qua
soprannomi stanno suicidando
e invece no ne vado vado a piantar
cooler invece no ragazzi che è cupo e
assurdo che c'è una trappola quindi dove
vado dove vado dove vado vado qua
perfetto modo salire ok quello in mezzo
no mai nella vita
questo sì rope forse già sto facendo non
fate domande non lo so ok qua non sarà
michael non lo so quando lo so non ne ho
idea cioè abbiate pazienza ma lo sapevo
lo sapevo che era con la destra lo
sapevo me lo stava dicendo una vocina
dentro me lo diceva porca [ __ ] con la
destra
la sigla testa a testa bene mi sto
tenendo da vabbè como che hanno fatto
l'ultima volta commento sarà mica il
terzo sì ok il secondo no risposta
sbagliata ok adesso non mi ricordo di
nuovo più come uno sbagliato dovevi
andare qua per te adesso qua non sarà
mai quindi devo andare direttamente sul
ma ci arrivo non ci arrivò mai ci provo
ci arrivo ci arrivo ci sono arrivato
miracolo divino i conigli anche qua i
coni basta sti cazzo di conigli che
cazzo facciamo sono vivo e botta di culo
non so non so come non l'ho toccata non
l'ho neanche toccata che voglio
veramente pregare con voi che questo sia
l'ultimo l'ultimo episodio di starò mai
non voglio non voglio neanche più vedere
robe simili bravo bravo bravo bravo
no cos'era la giusta era giusto per
fissare incassato la mia bene bene bene
bene bene bene bene male molto male come
tua madre male non voglio più fare un
pene dopo perché culo non ci arriva non
ci arriva più prima ci sono arrivato
adesso ho fatto un salto più in là di
così non ci arriverà mai allora che
cazzo cadi belli belli e allora perché
giochiamo a questa merda canon cadere
non cadere ma perché i ragazzi non si
basta non funziona più e si è rotto il
gioco non va più non so i razzi nel culo
come salto più di così no la madre
infestata dagli squali avevo bisogno di
sfogarmi ma entravo alcuni in casa mi
chiede se sto squartando un ovile tanto
a 5 ore fa ha fatto la stessa cosa e ha
funzionato
adesso non va ok madonna ragazzi io però
se muoio devono iniziare da zero regali
non ce la posso fare è mettere vi prego
vi supplico mettete un check point non
ci posso fare mai come fa cosa pace
mapper sorti
[Musica]
cazzo ero convinto che si potesse
passare in mezzo non lo so perché la
vostra convinzione proprio stato non
faremo ok doveva dove dove vado cosa
faccio ok cosa faccio chen traguardo ho
finito il 6 arrivo l'infinito il gioco
reagan o vi prego ragazzi non ci arriva
non ci arriva non ci arrivo arrivo
[Musica]
che culo happy days emersi dalla sorella
demo ma [ __ ] guardare le merde
merde ma da santa di quelle merde so sto
fuori di testa non avete idea di che
cazzo sto provando adesso come se mi
fossi innamorato proprio
l'estasi quindi ragazzi questo è stato
happy dead la demo per che uscirà al
gioco completo gli ovviamente lo
giocherò niente ragazzi è stato
bellissimo proprio un'esperienza che è
partita dal cuore ed è arrivata alla non
i ragazzi grazie per aver hanno
consigliato vi voglio bene come al
solito siete fantastici di consegnarmi
videogiochi quindi ragazzi conclude un
episodio che va seguito se vi è piaciuto
lasciato come te mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come ogni video
trovate la descrizione noi ci rivediamo
un prossimo video per ragazzi